We learned that Sweden
now has their own phone number
to finally get those confusing
Ikea instructions translated,
and I asked you to tell me
what you might hear
if you called
The America Number.
Let's dial it in. Carrot Top,
let's start with you.
All right.
You've reached America.
Before we get started,
I'd like to first apologize
for the senseless wars,
the Kardashians, the Republican
party, the Democratic party
and, of course, Carrot Top.
I'm very sorry.
I'm so sorry.
(applause)
MORRIS:
Very funny.
Thank you.
Why are you laughing at that?
Arden.
Thank you for calling America.
We can't come to the phone
right now
because we're morbidly obese
and the phone is way over there.
If you want to start a war
press one
or to talk to Emperor Trump
stay on the line.
-(applause)
-All right.
Lamorne.
Hey. Hey, what's goin' on?
You reached America.
I-It's Adam and Eve, not Adam
and Steve, you summamabitch.
Because if God wanted it
that way, he wanted two dudes
to be doing all this kind
of stuff, he would've
made 'em that way!
But instead you got a hole here
and you got a thing there
for babies to come out of.
All right.
(beep)
Leave your message.
"Is this thing still recordin'?!
What the (bleep)?"